the Lexx leak scandal took a turn for
the best as involved multinationals
finally appeared in front of mep s and
answer tough questions on their taxation
schemes in several EU member-states go
on saying that they agree with the
principle that the taxes should be paid
where the profit is made so there are
really a lot of inconsistent
inconsistencies in their words in their
speech and and this confirms that we
have got to move forward in terms of
legislation but Amazon coca-cola
facebook or HSBC are not yet out of the
woods as the special committee mandate
has been prolonged we got a lot of
documents very late we haven't got many
documents and that is a clear disrespect
of the European Commission and the
Member States and we need definitely
more time there is a clear signal of the
toxic coordinators to call for an
extension of the mandate by the end of
november mep will vote in plenary a
report that should ensure transparent
and fair corporate taxation throughout
europe